e chi è perché colora sicurezza di
strano viola benvenuti sono ligastory
oggi terzo episodio di tre colori di
pennarelli challenge con personaggi
horror paure oltre come sempre voi
dovrete votare per ogni turno se vinco
io se vince vitale in base a come
abbiamo colorato questi personaggi
in più abbiamo dei nuovi pennelli
trovando ho trovato lì nel cassetto
speriamo come sempre che i personaggi
horror non si arrabbino abbiamo tutti i
nuovi personaggi che ci avete
consigliato voi che la protesi se
scopriremo tale dovrà sempre indovinare
i nomi ogni capitale ha molti problemi
con i nomi non li farò mai nominato due
punti 96 tour che si chiami avete visto
l'episodio presente sapete di cosa sto
fare mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace
se volete anche la quarta parte e
scriveteci nei commenti quali sono gli
altri personaggi e bollette che colori a
gt pronti tranesi garnett mettevi comodi
ai e sono di gioco questa volta diverso
però in questa volta aggiungiamo anche i
pastelli al primo turno sono tantissimo
camera fornice sasso allora andiamo
innanzitutto svelare il nostro primo
versato inquietante personaggio in cui
piatto 3 2 1
come si chiama secondo te questo è
facile questo è il scream ice cream dire
gelato è lui a esprimere screen man si è
in pratica il gelataio cattivo ice cream
killer man
quindi questo è il gelataio ka di colore
lo faremo recco che prende un pastello a
cera lumia che camerino gli uomini sono
molto contento perche te che vado la
stretta ma leo messi male perché sia
questa cosa l'ho trovato a casa un pezzo
di baffo anche tu pastello a cera colore
rosso sarà perfetto pennarello anche
questo sarà molto bene vado io che cos'è
pastello a cera giallo vabbè ci porta
luce fare questi col calore per me
questo mi sembra un pennarello anche tu
giallo giallo vado io
lille cambierà un posto non poi girate
dallo frullino si gira allora non so se
fargli la faccio blu perdiamo che la
casa rosa o la faccia gialla
proviamo a rob lowe e finitura quella
e che il blu non gli sta male perché lo
trasforma in una sorta di ghiacciolo e
non piacciamo se non sbagliano un gelato
piacciono ma sembra proprio un
ghiacciolo la forma oppure un magnum
cuore gelato ok siamo pronti
un coloratissimo sicuramente sì
arrabbierò perché l'abbiamo fatto
colorato allegro nota come fossero tutti
e due carini fini adesso si chiama meno
tranne la faccia super malefica sono
molto carini allora votate il vincitore
io ho fatto la faccia blu magliettina
rosa e mani blu e poi il cappellino
giallo invece d'italia fatto la faccia
gialla come un simpson e il cappellino
rosso così come anche i guanti rossi e
la maglia invece rosalino rosso sì il
cappellino che sarebbe la febbre rosa è
in rosso
allora votate per il primo turno se
vinco io o se vince pitale passiamo al
secondo il coraggio pronti 321 e chi è
io non volevo farla perché troppo in
questa milano ha scritto il giorno mi
chiedete nei commenti di tirare fuori
questo personaggio inquietante come si
chiama secondo te io non lo so prova a
indovinare la professoressa cattivo e lo
stato chiede la professoressa bere bene
come vestita ai haven un testo non non
lui non vuol dire il mezzogiorno che le
tre ville nand bravo evil nun ce la
chiede sempre se volete facciamo anche
un gameplay e sul mio secondo canale
nintendo race 2 quindi andate subito
dopo questo video iscrivervi solita
stories due sedi scrivete andiamo a fare
anche gli impieghi evil nando perché non
ci ho mai giocato non dico che sia anche
se ha una faccia paura siamo cosa
facciamo carta francese buffa di nuovo
ci vuole diamo beh ci potrebbe pure
stare
amarone marrone che però questa volta
pennarello gambe
vorrei un'altra pastello o questo si sta
benissimo però vado io adesso il mio
colore preferito
tocca a me deve pescare l'ultimo marella
e secondo me questo è verde e nero
allora che abbiamo insomma fallire così
perché avete provato a camera abbiamo
preso quasi gli stessi colori funziona
si dai facciamo prendi le parti civili
religiose farle la faccia aiuto più
allora io voglio farla un po stile puffo
processo che si vendicherà si arrabbierà
quando faremo il gameplay ma voglio fare
una cosa sareste non copiano ed avere
tagli le di un colore diverso dal mio
che i fronti la nostra terribile hainan
una lettera che allora facciamola vedere
una alla volta
allora questa è la bussola miei film
hanno secondo me gli mancava qualcosa
quindi ho deciso di respingere le ali
che non sono da farfalla da angelo da
diavolo non lo so e anche la coda dietro
di o colorate marroni poi la faccia e
celeste tipo puffo il vestito è un po
blu gli occhi marroni e i denti marrari
vediamo ora cosa digitale eccola qua la
mia è come una lucertola una rettiliana
assomigliano certo la faccia il collo
che sono verdi il vestito la parte
bianca glie l'ho fatta celeste mentre
invece il vestito scuro glielo fatto
marrone non so se si vede dotato di tv
eventi gliel'ho fatto i celesti mesi
dovrete iscriversi il secondo poi qual è
il personaggio che inquietante di tutti
tra queste al momento questo perché col
ora c'è qualcosa di strano viola e tv
blu per il mio col nero come possibile
questa cosa è molto inquietante crescita
bambola chi era tutto ai fatti prima di
tale deve indovinare come si chiama
secondo te questa è la prova che voi lo
sapete la bambola scuola sposa bubble
bobble perché così presto ha vestito
come una sposa bambina è una favolosa di
annabella indovinato sap e no non è
stato creato in realtà e annabella bello
senza la finale ma comunque errori vedi
come è possibile che sia colorata
tra l'altro sono di due colori diversi
quasi qua sotto e tipo rosa ma il blu
scriveteci nei commenti se annabelle
tipo ma qualche qualche maledizione
strana
non l'ho mai visto il film scrivetemi se
voi l'avete visto ma so che tipo una
bambola e b 60 tipo chucky la bambola
assassina però queste tipo più
impossessato e forse fa cose un po
strane sinistra e di questo colore ma
che comunque noi la coloreremo sopra
vinceremo noi annabelle mi dispiace
perché dove c'è scritto ti manco a un
foglietto in mano guardate a un
foglietto in mano con scritto miss mi tv
diretti manco in inglese
spero che non sia indirizzato noi questo
biglietto comunque mi sono dimenticato
di dirvi lasciate un mi piace se volete
facciamo trovargli ingredienti stati
travolti da annabella ok vediamo che
inizia carta fanno disastro non aggiunto
oggi dittatura e vince allora si vuole
un bel colore scelto per la cera o il
tuo colore preferito
gli star abolizione dall'altra il calcio
il vestito verde una faccia verde
non male giallo puoi fare qualcosa di
carino toccare aspetti sera 10 associamo
prendo io sto cercando un pastello
freddi loro parole giallo è una cosa
seria pennarello lasciando comunque
attenzione non so se funziona per ora
proviamo prima vediamo se dice sì dai
bene bene bene anche se hanno aver
voleva restare di questo colore che non
si capisce sei un blu viola celeste e
noi lo facciamo di un altro cuore allora
secondo voi investito vert vestito rosso
rifrazioni testi torazza verte e vestito
rosso aiuto aiuto aiuto profeti la pace
tutta verde diventati proprio nei
distretti pronti con la nostra in cui
santissima anno bello stretto e facciamo
vedere uno alla volta il culo ecco
allora come potete vedere gli ho fatto
la pelle verde sembra veramente fiona
novabell finire poi i capelli glieli ho
fatti biondi i fiocchetti rossi il
vestito è il rosso anche se sembra un po
arancione anche le mani
nel bigliettino le ho risposto no perché
non mi manca casomai voglia venire a
trovarci meglio stare attenti che
vediamo una creatività invece avevo
fatto i capelli come i capelli color
color chucky diciamo come livello di
chucky non sono di trattare la ragione
la faccia gialla anche questa comun
simpson mentre il vestito e marrone
esatto mentre invece mi sono dimenticato
di colorare il bigliettino che arriva a
premi si no ok questo turno notte in cui
io possa lo vince vitale per i pro vita
allora le rughe sono entrambe inquieta e
ultimo turno è l'ultimo turno ultimo
personaggio
siete pronti a partire per che ha
accomunato anche questo come ferrovieri
lo stampato in bianco e nero non offrono
come è possibile che colorato ai devi
indovinare e un jack kate e jack lo
sport a tor e no non è libera e jack
jack cosa vigatto jack cosa dica che
questa sarebbe la coda avessi te un
piede di porco
cosa si aspetta ancora di gatto piede di
porco attento sarai più fortunato snai
come si chiama alfredo alfredo alfredo
cosa di gatto ma che ci riprova non lo
so sapete chi è lui evo di brutto e lui
si sta inventando i loghi abbiamo anche
giocato questo gioco mister nut quindi
sic lo conosci no è troppo magro per
essere mister mette di non conosco mario
dal mare gremito è crema
medica lo sapevi come mai averlo
riconosciuto è perché viola
certo che può outlander man devo dire
perché abbia questo colore e io l'ho
stampato il bianco e nero sarà la
maledizione di questi personaggi che non
vogliono lo scelgono l'uomo il colore
mamma mia
vediamo cosa ci capita form in basso
ho preso questo beige visto che ti è
sempre capitato il marrone in ogni turno
questa volta vecchi ma con una
straordinaria nella sabbia sporca
ora voglio prendere questa anche se non
so che cos'è pastello a cera giallo
giallo e che credo che con la rete
riprendermi il mio pastello nuovamente
che costa blu gruppo nuovo puffo e si
perde è stata ultimo colore per me
ecco adesso fuori bello questo bel
colore arancione sono uguali questi 29
marrone torna
ah ok nonno grandi sono felice di queste
genti un altro alieno tutti prodotti
pronti se volete altri challenge alle 3
di notte lasciato un bel mi piace su
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace faremo un'altra sala in sole 13
pratica non lo faccio perde però mi sa
che lo faccio diventare un vero e
proprio alieno anche con questa testa
pelata
allora vi spiego li ho fatti li stavo
facendo la faccia blu però poi copriva
la faccia e quindi ho continuato
converte o chi perde queste sono foglie
perché questo credimi se come sono io
tutto bastone
ho deciso di fare un potere in più
iniziative richiesti con lauree al core
e in pratica dal suo vaccolino spara
dardi di energia verde
il nonno e il palco lino magica macolino
maledetto per renderlo più cattivo
comunque questo è il mio nonno che remi
cosa ne pensate
un nonno molto grip con la loro in testa
di appena laureata nel super dark la
faccia ocra il vestito marroncino i
pantaloni stile jeans così come anche il
bastone blu ed è nelle tenebre della
notte qui c'è anche alla luna questa
sarebbe la luna è sì allora ma come ma
come segni la luna perché sono sotto
come questa è la forma di e la luce
della luna di neanche una forma
reginella la cosa che raramente la luna
quasi un voto alla luna diventare da uno
zio giudice è un po più inquietante
invece più simpatico colbacco lino
magico votate chi vince questo tour o se
vinco io o se vince vitale ok ragazzi
questo era l'ultimo sì ma ci sarà un
altro episodio se lasciate un mi piace
qui sotto se questo video raggiunge i 10
mila mi piace ci sarà un altro episodio
sempre con i personaggi consigliati da
voi quindi scriveteci nei commenti gli
altri personaggi e se non avete visto
gli altri episodi via l'altra volta
siamo finiti in pareggio mi sembra
nell'altro allen giorno quindi non ha
vinto lì solo di due quindi dovete
andare a votare celine curiosamente
vitale così vediamo chi ha vinto nello
scorso episodio vi lasciamo ora alla
casa e lì dietro e cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione